When we think of a mass on a spring, there's only two numbers initially that we really care about.
One is the mass of the block and the other is K,
which is a constant associated with the spring that measures its stiffness.
For example, a rubber band sort of spring. And it would have a very low K since it's not very stiff.
The springs in your car on the other hand would have a very high K
because they're very stiff and hard to compress.
Now right now this mass spring totally in equilibrium. This is exactly where the mass wants to be.
Let's imagine displacing this mass from equilibrium. So let's move the center of mass over to here.
So we've displaced our spring from equilibrium by a distance
that I'm going to call Xmax, and you'll see why I called it that in a second.
Now if I pull this mass back to Xmax and release
what's going to happen is it's going to undergo a series of oscillations.
In fact, if we assume that this surface is frictionless it's going to oscillate forever.
Of course that would never happen in real life but let's talk ideal-wise here.
In fact, this mass will swing through the equilibrium position here
and all the way back to distance of -Xmax from the equilibrium.
So now you can see the reason why called this max is because as these
oscillations continue this is the farthest from equilibrium that the mass will ever reach.
Now what I want to do is analyze this spring in terms of energy,
which we talked about a ton in the last unit.
Well it turns out that the potential energy stored in the spring
is equal to half the spring constant K times x².
X in this case would be whatever the current displacement from the equilibrium is.
So when the mass is at the equilibrium, x will be 0. When the mass was over here, it will be Xmax.
Maybe here it would be 1/2 of Xmax and so on.
And so if we looked at let's say three possible positions for where the mass could be
in its back and forth oscillations.
So the position 1, equilibrium. Position 2 and this is sort of midpoint. And position 3, Xmax.
So you need to tell me for each of these three positions as the spring is oscillating back and forth
what kind of energy does it have at each of these positions?
Check all boxes that you think apply.
And remember we're talking about kinetic energy, the energy of motion
and potential energy, which in this case is spring potential energy and not gravitational potential.